what's up everyone i'm chef bree also
known as breezy jacks and today we are
here to make
some homemade pop-tarts inspired by
president obama's visit to ted's
bulletin in dc
he ordered a burger and some homemade
pop-tarts for dessert so that's what
we're gonna get busy with today
[Music]
okay so to start for our homemade
pop-tarts we're going to make our
filling
this needs to cool so we want to start
with this so as we make our pastry dough
it's already chilled out and ready to go
so to begin we're going to mix some corn
starch with some water
this is also known as a cornstarch
slurry it will help
thicken our jam so we have a nice thick
filling and we don't have leaking jam
from our pop-tart filling
so once this is good we'll get it in our
pot
add the jam
we want to bring this to a boil so i'm
going to be on like medium high heat
break this apart and incorporate it
now i can tell this is going to be thick
to seize now that we've reached a boil
we're going to let it
stay here in this state for about two
minutes so we get a nice thick
filling and consistency you want to
constantly stir
as it boils so that nothing sticks and
burns at the bottom of your pan
our jam is nice and thick
so we are going to pour it out into
our bowl and move on to making our
cinnamon filling
all right so our cinnamon filling is so
basic and so straightforward we are
going to mix
some flour some cinnamon
and some brown sugar and just use a
whisk
and break that up and all together the
flour
just like the cornstarch is going to
help bind this and bring it together as
it bakes in our pastry filling
get all your frustrations out with
everything happening in politics
just beat these little granules of sugar
up
we will set this aside to just relax
it's already done all the hard work
and we're going to move on to making the
most fun part of all the pastry crust
so now we're moving on and we're going
to make our pastry dough
and that requires some flour
sugar and salt salt sounds crazy to have
in desserts for some people i know
but it really balances the sweetness of
the sugar if you add the salt in there
want to just mix this
incorporate all of that together with a
fork and once you don't see any sugar
granules
we're going to cut in our butter you
want nice
cold cubed butter here and you can use
your hands but i'm going to use a pastry
cutter
and get these nice and small about the
size of a pea
just incorporate all of the butter into
the dry
and now we're going to mix our wet
ingredients together
so some milk
and an egg if you're cool you can do it
with one hand
[Applause]
just whisk this together real good
and using that same fork or your hands
incorporate the wet into your dough
you will reach a point where you will
have to go in with your hands but
starting off with a fork is always best
and get in here you really want to work
this dough with your hands
and get it nicely incorporated so that
the dough sticks to itself
you'll probably need to knead the dough
for about five minutes
max until it forms a ball and sticks to
itself
and you don't have any dry pockets you
kind of want to follow the rules of the
[ __ ]
you want a wet ass pastry here you don't
want any dry
pastry pockets once we get our dough
into a nice
ball and it all sticks together we're
going to divide this into two
make a disc and roll them out working
with one half at a time we got some
beautiful layers in there just
gonna be delicious i'm gonna lightly
dust our parchment paper
so the dough doesn't stick make a nice
little disc again
i'm working semi-quickly so we don't
melt too much of the butter in there
because that's what gives us a nice
flaky dough
gonna put a little bit of flour on our
rolling pin and get rolling
we want these to be about an eighth of
an inch thick
that way your pastry dough cooks through
all the way and you don't have any of
the filling leaking out
and we're going to cut this into a nine
by 12 inch
rectangle measure down the middle get
these sides
going
you do this with both halves of our
dough so we have our bottom
pastry and our top pastry now that we
have our
big rectangle we're going to cut our
small rectangles
and get to assembling so i'm going to go
for the halfway mark
and one more time
and now we'll move this onto our sheet
tray and start assembling them
all right so now it's on to the fun part
of assembly
so i have three bottoms for our three
strawberry fillings
so before we get to building we need to
make an egg wash
so i have an egg and some milk
an egg wash is just like food glue it's
going to help
bind our pastry together use a little
pastry brush
and just go all the way around the edges
we're even going to use some of this egg
wash on the top of our pop tarts to give
it a little
glow and a summer color getting nice and
brown
into the middle we're going to put this
nice thick strawberry jam that we made
let's break that up a little bit
and a spoonful into each one
if you want to get in there with your
fingers and spread it around
it'll also spread as it bakes but you
want to help it out a little bit
next we're going to top them off
[Music]
use your fingers and kind of pinch them
together like you would if you're making
pasta
just to seal in that jam
i like to overlap them make a nice
little
crimp design i can definitely see while
making these
why president obama just had to have one
for dessert after that burger
and just going to repeat this with all
of them until they're ready to go
we're going to poke a few holes in the
top and this is also important so that
as it bakes that steam
can release out of the middle of the
pastry
and bake evenly and nicely last little
bit of egg wash and we'll build
our cinnamon pop-tarts next so our
last three same steps here just a
different feeling
just want to egg wash then next we're
going to do the same thing put a
tablespoon of filling
right in the middle this is a dry mix so
you want to be a little careful
when spooning it into the center so it
doesn't go out too far
on your edges as a kid brown sugar was
definitely
my favorite and i'd always put it in the
toaster to get it nice and warm on the
inside
for a little extra razzle dazzle before
school same thing
pat it on there make those crimps gonna
get our little
air pockets in there final egg wash
nice and moisturize [ __ ] on a nice wet
pastry top
we're going to let these rest in the
refrigerator for about 15 minutes so
that butter can chill up again
before going into the oven and while
those are baking
we are going to make two different
icings for our two different pop-tarts
i'm gonna make our cinnamon icing first
in a bowl we've got our powdered sugar
milk some vanilla
and cinnamon whisk this all together
i think these treats are perfect for the
cold weather
that we kind of had coming up in la faux
fall as i like to call it that we have
these are nice and warm with those
cinnamon flavors it just
tastes like fall
so next we've got strawberry icing which
is just
same ingredients but no cinnamon and
just like that
we've got our icings so using a
tablespoon i'm just going to
pour it right over the top and let the
icings drizzle
all around our pastry
i cannot wait to bite into these and get
my
obama on and feel real presidential
while reading these special treats
while these were in the oven i was doing
my part
researching propositions and people on
the ballot so i know what i'm going into
when i step into the polling place
because you don't want to be unprepared
the vote matters so do your research
people
all right the moment has finally arrived
we are
done making our presidential pop-tart
[Music]
let's get into it
wow i can't even talk a bite into this
amazing
cinnamon brown sugar filling i i feel
presidential eating this like i feel
so special
this strawberry is amazing i got a nice
chunk from the strawberry jam in that
first bite and just had to take a moment
and say thank you because that was
delicious
i might have to put one of these in my
pocket when i go to the polling place
and help give me a little energy and a
boost as i
vote i am so happy
if you want to understand how i'm
feeling and feel real presidential at
home
give these a try highly recommend it 10
out of 10.
this was probably the best wet ass
pastry i have
ever had the pleasure of enjoying and i
hope you guys enjoy it too
go rock the vote do all that good stuff
make the big man over there proud and
enjoy
[Music]
you